well that could have gone better yeah as
you can see the weird my pocalypse has
hit it's encased Rob in this prison ball
oh yeah but but was nice enough put the
little maple symbol on there because
obviously he's a big fan of Mabel uh I
got a little easier they just took my
dipper head and shaved my sideburns
that's about it um
so good kind of lucky me you know um
yeah I don't quite get how I end up in
prison
but you can just run around town without
a problem you know what it's not it's
not without a problem I haven't missed
the cypher and since I was like a little
kid okay I've always had sideburns now
they're gone it's just I feel in prison
I'm probably more in prison than you are
right now okay we like breaking the
fourth wall because I was talking about
the show oh yeah okay
yeah because like Mabel ends up in
prison but dipper kind of gets to run
around and I'm like why is he it like
cuz bill encounters him and then just
lets him go basically actually writes
the journals which was like a oh fuck
well no she sounds like one of the
monsters ago after him or whatever but
uh I think it was kind of thankful like
you know I guess he died dipper didn't
really have that much to contributing to
the weird appleís by Bobby or whatever
apocalypse for all the people just like
who everybody blames Mabel or dipper or
uncle Ford but nobody blames Bill we'll
bill just thanked uncle Ford so suck on
that there's this weird thing where like
everyone was in this big who's to blame
who's to blame like it was a clear who
kick it's clearly dipper cares i Alta
you you're the first time because of you
know even the first time I saw it I like
I just didn't assume this was like a
blame thing I thought it's just more
like okay this is just like a tragedy
just like all these things happen you
know I know if I was God you have no
idea how the internet works do you that
clearly but you started in my friend
okay didn't start it but you were hey I
was just ahead of the curve
I'll just have a curve ah but never let
let's talk about some respect that like
most people on the internet they're just
in a bubble um so that's right take that
everybody watching me um but let's talk
about this episode um this is kind of
like every apocalyptic show movie
whatever that you've seen like in an
episode I like you got Mad Max uh with
um Gideon II that was my favorite yeah
yeah Walking Dead with Wendy you kind of
have as she put every metal cover ever
heavy metal fan cover ever that was my
favorite line cuz I literally was
thinking that it was like wow this looks
like something out of metal rock it's
kind of every B movie where aliens
attack and stuff is kind of in there uh
and it's it's wonderfully creative I
even down to the opening sort of
retooling that and have II will bill
cipher's take it over and they're even
ng a lot of a kiss kind of cryptic too
like when the monster looks at the
skeleton a difference just like wow
that's actually kind of different
because you the animation for the whole
series has been really good and there's
been no dip or drop no not are in uh in
the animation but it it's it's like
whatever maybe extra cash Disney was
like you know what we'll we'll give you
like an extra million or something here
like it went into these episode you know
it's one of those things
George ously animated because I mean
they're on hiatus so often that maybe it
is like no no no we we really want to as
much effort as possible into like this
big episode I'm assuming is the you know
the ending of series 2 you know that
there's another one coming out next week
it's a big to be continued um but ya
know the animations gorgeous the stuff
they're kind of satirizing like it's a
Mad Max and everything is gorgeous I
mean we love Mad Max if you can't tell
so to see them doing all that was great
um and they didn't like that there was
something about when he's like oh the
car park really it's abandoned the
second I saw that side that said Gideon
sucks or whatever name was changed to
awesome I like oh shit giving instead
yeah guys like that I should
background like you could just see
Gideon changing it yeah why those little
um it's my name
it's my faith um there's something about
again you kind of know you have a good
environment and caste and it's just a
good product when something like this
happens the weird
acha lips and you want to see how it
affects everybody and in there should
and we I keep saying we're that glad
that oculus yeah I got getting rights
very important um but yeah there's
something I love seeing how it affects
everybody it's kind of like what I
enjoyed seeing all the symptoms for a
while it's like when so in the Halloween
episodes it's like oh here's a cool idea
let's see how it affects everybody but
even with that you kind of have like
these little whatever 10-minute not even
any more segments of the Halloween
specials where they do it here you can
have not only a whole episode on another
episode on top of that uh next time
finger yes I'm still in the fucking
bubble still a boo-boo
um but oh speaking of fucking bubbles
that's easy oh yeah yeah the the weird
bubbles of the cam silencers when they
switch I think so if not it's your look
tip like not that shame on them that
should have been I'm pretty sure it was
cuz I think like if it let lay put this
way if it wasn't why when they get a boy
to play dipper that was clearly a grow a
groan dude yeah I'm pretty sure that's
why he looks like the voice actor um so
and like if they've done stuff like that
before like they can the voice actors
together to like just sing the theme
song and stuff for a YouTube video so
why why when they do that I don't know
why by the sudden urge to eat worms fly
south or nest I have an urge to just
talk to people like louis c.k about
getting in my mouth
oh are you getting in my mouth just that
I you know and I'm just calm I see I
love a show like this I can just bring
in these people that just like it we all
kind of like and just you know just rip
for no fucking reason it all makes it so
great it's great like because it's like
if Lucy Kay just honestly sir turned out
that way like I'm a monster whatever
it's like that's what he would do slowly
I'd be like this
show is turning into the gremlins 2 of
animated shows or it's just like why did
you do that because I can yes and God
watch it for its kind of amazing on and
this is not one of those episodes where
it's like with most of them like when
they come to an end it's like ok it
feels about the right time for this
episode come to an end stuff I need this
one I'm really glad it's a two-parter
cuz it is like I just I want to see more
of it this is like one of the most
enjoyable apocalypses like I've ever
seen
and I think that discusses a variety of
weird and the writing odd things
hey-oh I'm sure we'll get her in the
next one I'm curious what that prison
bubble is gonna be because we've already
seen how weird he's made the rest of the
world oh let me - you have no idea you
have no fucking idea what oh yea cuz I
cuz you're in there right now right this
is yours hasn't gotten to that giant
size yet that Mabel's has got this shit
I'm seeing oh my god they're in enough
acid in the world to compete I can't
like the umm I like that gideon kind of
changes around - i actually bought that
okay I'm usually not super big on when
villains like do the total turnaround on
something in turn good but I was like it
seemed okay fell okay she's trapped in a
bubble was he just gonna make out with a
bubble no but I know he assumes like oh
I'll get to her eventually I'll win my
charms I'll blob a blonde he's realizing
know if he's gonna do this you know if
there's any generalizing when he talks
to defer that like yes she's not gonna
be happy with me no matter cuz like the
world's gone to shit hmm yeah he's about
everything um I love how all the
prisoners love Gideon that would that
was really enjoy I like that half the
prisoners are like you know philosophy
majors yes um acting you know uh we
don't see any of Mabel we see very
little Stan in this - he runs away from
the go - that's about it I like to think
that some sort of Jurassic Park revenge
by the way what's gonna happen to the
goat haha
turns it to like a giant t-rex um yeah
cuz if I had to assume if I had to make
a guess I'd say that maybe the next
episode he's gonna come in and do
something because yeah there was very
little of him than this one I'll sing
with soos y-yeah he comes in a little
bit
no he didn't do anything but now I think
now that he's hooked up with them
he said that Wendy's arm is okay and
that they're surrounded so well they're
all singing folk song yes that is really
cool guys are good it's come on fucking
Bardstown no they really got they really
kind of got usable it's like all of the
post-apocalypse yeah it's like it's a
satire of like the cliches but it also
feels very legit there's still that
weight to it and that's why I love about
this show you can't sir have like those
cypher is a perfect example of something
that could be really really funny but
also had this intimidation to him is
what he killed time baby
I mean just like pointing his head and
why just because he can and it's fun and
he's just like yeah but what's gonna
blow out that's kind of what I wanna
find you who like party I also love all
his minions they kind of look like the
ones that didn't quite make the audition
cut for a real monster I also like when
the Thai cops show up to as far as I can
all right everybody be cool be cool
everybody be cool be cool I got this
don't say anything
uh yeah which again kind of makes you
wonder why I'm cops I'm still okay I got
a city still can't really take bill
seriously oh no I didn't say he's some
of you take seriously it's something
days like he's hilarious
but these people do and I'm like they're
like we need to play bill he's like the
puppet in this announcing you know what
I feel like they'd be giving bill what
he wants I don't wanna do that like I
can't quit or so no said he can't take
him seriously I don't give bill what he
wants I don't I don't cuz that's that's
what he'd be expecting oh I'm in a
fucking bubble so I'm gonna give it to
him I love the fact that his hat has
bone in it because when they shoot
through the hat the bone actually like
it that's together through the Hat um
but yeah what an interesting - you know
you have the you know Y that map or
whatever of all the symbols bill cipher
and then the circle round of all the
symbols ah you know there's always these
symbols that say ok clearly that's
supposed to be different it's supposed
to be maple and stuff when they put her
in the bubble the symbol that's in there
is also in there so you're almost
wondering if like maybe he has to get
all of them to complete the circle or
something like that or may it's just
coincidence I'm I'm just glad the odd
apocalypse respects my fashion sense yes
is it with the shooting star the more
you know star
um the more you know actually I think in
the ad pocalypse it's the less you know
yeah um so I'm trying to think what else
I it's a great setup it's I just don't
usually see this as send it to like all
the Apocalypse movies and shows and
stuff it's usually like what an
apocalypse it was all yeah it the all
Apocrypha all papi all consulates yes
there you go
there's something about um you know cuz
whatever they do apocalypse at times
it's always like one it's always like
the Omega Man or like Walking Dead or
playing the Aves or something like that
but it's like they got them all kind of
in this one or at least a good best of
moody man man I mean how fucking amazing
yes uh I got really excited when I saw
that and they and again if serve like
they're making fun of it but they really
know to show like the cars getting
ramped up and all the cool angles when
they're driving and stuff like that
kills me though it's like Gideon's dad
into used cars and everything they fit
organically into the plot it's not like
a really bad Simpsons episode yeah
they're desperate to find a way to make
this work it's like that somehow just
worked naturally like all the way back
in the beginning is a used car
dealership we know it's there we know
Gideon's got a connection we know it
exists he goes to prison he's got all
these prisoners it all fell into place
yeah no I I thought worked out very very
well um so yeah anything else I it's a
good episode I can't wait for this thing
but about uncle Ford and those journals
going up in flames where's your Messiah
now differ still that one page that he's
gonna bring I hope yeah I hope something
I did my jaw drop that was like like
when uncle Ford bought it I'm like okay
well like I could probably see didn't
die I know but I know when he's like got
turned into a fucking back scratcher um
I was like okay well I could probably
see that coming when they burned the
journals I was like no um well and that
does bring up a question like even after
whatever this all gets resolved or
wherever where's the show gonna go cuz I
mean it's like it kind of seems like
they're answering like a lot of the
questions we might be in the endgame
dude I mean I mean he said it was
supposed to take place over summer
how long is fucking summer what he and
they said the summers
anything and everything I mean they'd
honestly I'd be shocked if they didn't
do like a spinoff I'm not gonna lie if
this just like petered out after like
you know three or four episodes are now
resolved all this I'd be satisfied I'm
like I got I know I was good it sucks
it's gonna end but you know what do a
couple of spin-off specials and I I hate
to say that I'm I'm I really want to see
more and I want to see more great stuff
come from because I love so much more
I've always wanted I think we this way
but I would view if it ended now would
be very much like avatar that was like a
perfect run a great way to go about a
good beginning middle and end everything
so I'm kind of with you even though I
don't want to see it I think you're
right rather want more than to be like
oh my god this should have gone off the
air two seasons yeah almost case that
would have worked
yeah but you know just two seasons but
but at the same time there is something
that's like okay so like now that we're
done with season two it's like let's
change it up let's try something
different with gravity falls that's
still in the spirit it's still really
cool let's send them on like a new quest
or a new journey or something as well so
I don't know series you could have the
next summer you could have a winter
break and be interesting yeah that'd be
very addressed there's an other school
breaks there's a spring break there's a
winter break summer breaks out the only
one yeah well that's all I'm talking
about I mean like they could fit go
somewhere else we could still be a few
tweaks on the break you know you get 14
episodes out of that at least hmm um so
or if you just do it hour by hour you
could get way more so yeah no I actually
look before you go Alex Hirsch like this
guy like who the hell knows what other
ideas he has he may be like yeah I don't
know part one of like a billion ideas
with billions of other characters and
other universes and I know I just really
like ready follow though will be awesome
if you created other shows that are in
the same multiverse yeah that would be
pretty cool they have like the Marvel
spin-off movies yeah the Alex Hirsch
feel like even they're like the Joe
Dante films I think there was this
argument that a lot of them are in say
multiverse cuz explorers had that a
headline about the disaster and Kingston
Falls difference so maybe there's a joke
Dante universes and everything you know
oh yes yeah I see satisfied I would too
and want to see more I want to see more
but I'm like I wouldn't leave this going
oh well what a shitty place to end there
ya know what you oh yeah all right yeah
so um that's about in we'll see you at
Part two and get me out of this bubble
fucking bubbles no really it's called
you know it's cold without sideburns